okay 2015 let's see what you got at the
start of any given year seems like
pretty much everybody puts out some sort
of video blog what have you about their
most anticipated whatever movies video
games comic books etc for the new year
so i thought i would throw together my
most anticipated movies of 2015 my
intention had been for this to be a top
10 list but something funny kind of
happened when i actually looked at the
full list of all the movies coming out
this year i couldn't actually come up
with ten that i was truly genuinely
excited about I could have bulked it out
to ten easily enough cherry picked a few
of the ones that I'm hopeful for but
notting actually genuinely excited about
yet and stuck them in there just to get
to that magical tenant number but you
know what I've got more integrity than
that so I decided to only put the movies
on this list that I genuinely am excited
for now there are movies that I'm not
going to talk about that I do plan to
see and I hope will be good the kingsmen
Terminator Genisys Tomorrowland movies
like that are ones that I do hope to see
and that I do hope will be good i've
even got a glimmer to believe that they
will be good but those movies and others
like them they're either in some reason
for me to question that it may not be
good maybe there's a bad history to this
franchise in other cases i'm just really
hopeful but i don't have a lot of
concrete stuff to go that's why I know
it's gonna be awesome and that's where
stuff like tomorrow land falls in so
limiting myself to the ones that I am
truly genuinely pumped about I've got
six starting with chappie latest film
from neill blomkamp this one sells me
pretty much on premise and trailer i
thought the trailers that have come out
so far are really interesting and really
engaging looks like there's some good
angles going on there and I like stories
of things sort of coming into their own
and coming to a new level of
consciousness and you get that with a
good sort of robot learning more about
the world and about itself type story
the effects look great i'm sure there's
got to be plenty of action in it i'm not
actually as big a fan of neill blomkamp
as it seems like a lot of people are
district nine was good it was fine I
think it was over height slightly I mean
the guys are reliable and he's choosing
to play in a sandbox that I like a lot
so yeah I'm gonna see that number five
mad max fury road this is what I was
pretty much sold completely on the
strength of the trailers that have come
out because i'm not a huge Mad Max fan
I've seen bits and pieces of the various
movies I've seen most of road warrior I
was kind of like the notion of it but
I'd never hooked me for some reason but
these trailers and the action that we're
saying and how much of it was clearly
done practically and they shot on
location in a desert and just George
Miller's I and the way some of these
images are composed and then just the
raw energy that is in these trailers I I
just think this is gonna be a absolute
blast well you know what sometimes I
just want a really kick-ass ride and I
think that is exactly what Mad Max is
gonna give me my fourth most anticipated
Shaun the Sheep yes animated kids movie
animation junkie remember and I of
course love Wallace and Gromit I love
all the work that argument Studios is
pretty much ever done so I mean just the
name aardman alone sells me on the
notion of at least giving this a shot
but Shaun the Sheep is a great character
and it's a great world and what I'm most
fascinated about it does look like from
the trailers that have been shown so far
that they're sticking to the heart of
the original show which is that Shaun
the Sheep doesn't speak he boss from
time to time you know the animals they
make their noises the farmer kind of
goes lu lu every now and then but by and
large it's gonna play a bit like a
silent film there's not going to be
dialogue there's not going to be talking
animals and if anybody can pull off 90
minutes of no talking but you are
riveted to the screen with wonderful
characters and terrific whimsy and just
great fun aardman can do it number 3
star wars the force awakens everyone
seems to have put star wars at the top
of the most anticipated list I'm still
just too jaded from how much crap has a
Star Wars fan I've taken up to this
point and though I like JJ Abrams and I
like what he does for the most part I
don't have enough faith to put this at
the top that said I'm still excited for
this that first trailer did a lot to
sort of way lame any of my fears it
didn't necessarily give me more pumped
than I already was just for the notion
of a new Star Wars movie but it's
certainly game
the reassurance that it was not going to
be making so many of the mistakes that
the prequels made I mean just visually
it's so uncluttered it's so clean it
felt like original Star Wars it didn't
feel like the prequels and that alone
wasn't just a huge relief and I just
hope they can pull this off number two
Spectre I love me some James Bond and
Skyfall was amazing him one of the
biggest promises of Skyfall was that it
basically ended setting up bond in the
form that we knew him for the longest it
sets up the money penny and em in that
office and all that sort of classic
stuff from the sort of Sean Connery
error of James Bond and so now that
we're gonna get spat your back and Sam
Mendes is going back to direct them
again and Daniel Craig is still on but I
could not be more excited for this movie
there is one more I am slightly more
pumped for though and I think you all
know what it is avengers age of ultron
not a huge surprise that this is
occupying the top spot although honestly
that first teaser trailer with the use
of i've got no strings that is probably
will put it up over the top they use of
that song in that tone and how many
times i watched and re-watched and riri
riri watch that trailer if it hadn't
been for that masterful bit of teasing
spectrum I to beat it out for the top
spot but but there it is Avengers right
where it belongs the movie that I am
most excited about seeing in 2015 so I
wasn't able to come up with a top ten
that is kind of an indication that maybe
2015 not gonna be as good a years 2014
there were a lot of good movies in 2014
for my way of thinking but you know what
the fact that I have fewer movies that
I'm all that excited about gives 2015
more room to surprise me and one of my
favorite things is to be surprised so
you know what gauntlet is thrown down
2015 let's see you pick it up and beat
me with it what about you what are your
most anticipated movies for this year
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned